we are joined now by jeremy siegel here
as the market opens the professor from
warden steps in to help us figure some
of these things out from his campus in
Philadelphia professor thanks for
joining us let me ask first you know not
a lot of people remember or know that
the Bush administration actually wanted
you to join the Federal Reserve Board of
Governors you declined and but today
we're seeing central bank action at its
best actually credibility at its worst
for the Swiss National Bank what do you
make of this move well I'm not surprised
at all by this move and and the reason
is because of the sinking euro you know
they the euro has gone down from about
142 we know around 115 it might go down
even more and basically essentials I'm
not going I'm not going to tie my ship
to a sinking boat you know so really
what they're doing is revaluing it I
really don't think this has terrible
international consequences i think it's
almost entirely due to the euro sinking
if the euro had stayed around 130 you
would not see this swiss bank action
professor was this also an anticipation
of more action a move by Mario Draghi on
the twenty-second coming up yeah I mean
I think that you know the market is
discounting a healthy round of QE by the
European Central Bank you know draghi's
kind of smiling at the fall the exchange
rate you know I've called for the fall
of the euro for a long time I was always
puzzled how it stood up there at one
thirty five forty for so long with a
sinking economy but finally we are
getting that move I think that move in
the euro downward is going to produce a
better 2015 for the European economy
than many people project right now and I
think Draghi wants to bring it down to
110 we've heard talk of parity you know
certainly that's pasa
I don't think maybe he wants it to go
quite down that far but that's the
reason for the central bank move in
Switzerland anticipation of Draghi and
the the twenty percent declined that
we've already seen in the euro professor
the Swiss have always culturally held
themselves to be distinct from Europe
this island in the center of the
European Union that has nothing to do
with the economies around it but they're
not as distinct as they wish they were
right no no no no clearly they're not
now the Swiss currency has been I would
say maybe the strongest in the world
certainly now that Japan under Abhi's a
depreciation policy has you know fallen
back you know Swiss central bank Swizz
monetary powers he has been the soundest
lowest inflation and they've maintained
their economy despite the fact that the
the rest of Europe is going down so
they're saying listen I don't want to
sync with Europe I rather and they're
not really even in terms of the US
dollar I check the exchange rate they're
not as as high as they were let's say
six months ago so they're only brought
themselves partly back to the dower they
probably want to bring themselves a
little bit further but they're saying
hey you know with the sinking euro I
can't tie my boat to a sinking ship so
again I'm not surprised I don't think
that this is really going to cause any
serious repercussions in the world
currency markets I think it is entirely
you again to the sinking euro that we've
seen over the last six months that it
looks like it's going to sink more under
further policy by the European Central
Bank well in it I have to ask what you
what you think the reasons are behind
the sink and euro beyond central bank
policy I mean they have real problems
with the economy real problems with
demands there does that affect us does
that continue there and does that affect
us i guess the two-part question yeah I
mean you know why was it staying so high
for so long and the reason is it's
actually because Europe despite its
problems and
particularly Germany at the center was
still running a healthy trade surplus so
currency traders did not really want to
put a lot of bets on depreciating
currency you know when when you have a
trade surplus but given how low the
economy is gone given the anticipation
of a quantitative easing further easing
by dragging in the central bank finally
currency traders have said hey yeah they
want to talk down the euro and I'm not
going to resist this so despite the
trade surplus they are moving down by
the way the trade surplus in Europe ill
probably get stronger I think a weaker
currency is really going to help Greece
Spain Portugal the peripheral countries
you know it might be one of the cheapest
vacations around now to go to the Greek
Isles if the Euro goes down to parity
and you know the hey that could be one
of the best things happening for the the
Greek economy same true in Spain and
Portugal which really rely a lot on on
tourism but also on exports of to some
extent and olive oil and other things
that they're doing so this is good for
Europe the sinking economy the city not
sinking euro it will help you the
European economy that ultimately is
going to good for the world economy and
the US economy all right professor
Siegel Brendan and I will bring you a
bottle of olive oil back from our cruise
to Mykonos